it's good
ladies and gentlemen and welcome to the
national churchill library and center my
name is michael bishop and i'm the
director of the library and the
executive director of the international
churchill society the society was
founded 50 years ago and is dedicated to
preserving and promoting the historic
legacy of winston churchill through
publications
and events such as our upcoming 35th
international churchill conference this
weekend
in colonial williamsburg
to learn more about churchill and the
society please visit us online at
winstonchurchill.org
the national churchill librarian center
is the result of a partnership between
the university and the society and over
the last two years we have welcomed many
students and visitors and shared with
them access to primary documents books
and exhibits about winston churchill
including a painting by churchill which
you can see
over there
for our churchill conversations series
we've welcomed to the library leaders
such as ambassador ron dermer david
rubinstein general david petraeus
former pakistani president proves
musharraf actor gary oldman
distinguished historians including neil
ferguson and many more to discuss not
only the particulars of churchill's life
and career but their application to our
present day challenges
for as churchill himself observed the
longer you can look back the farther you
can look forward
but now let us turn to the main event
tonight we will learn about a figure
utterly devoted to history who in his
thirties wrote an admiring biography of
a conservative victorian statesman and
who has chronicled the history of wars
around the world
amid a colossal output of non-fiction in
his youth he wrote a single novel
featuring a protagonist modeled rather
closely after himself and engaged in a
struggle against tyranny
a passionate polemicist his articles on
a host of political and historical
subjects appeared in newspapers and
magazines in britain and around the
world
a fervent admirer of napoleon a devout
drinker of paul reger champagne
a confidant of prime ministers and
habituate of 10 downing street and an
honored guest at the white house he has
truly made his mark on history
one of the reasons the many reasons that
andrew roberts may be the perfect
biographer of winston churchill is that
the above description applies equally to
them both
in his i'd spotted that coming up
actually in his
you should read the novel in his uh
please dance
that's what churchill said about his
in his memoirs of the second world war
churchill reflected on the moment when
ultimate power came to him in may 1940 i
was conscious of a profound sense of
relief at last i had the authority to
give directions over the whole scene
i felt as if i were walking with destiny
and that all my past life had been but a
preparation for this hour and for this
trial
after decades of research ceaseless
travel in the great man's footsteps and
the use of new sources andrew roberts
has crafted a brilliant exploration of
churchill's walk with destiny but it's
not the new sources that most
distinguish this path-breaking work
rather it is the calm and reasoned
judgment that andrew applies to the
countless dramas triumphs
failures and controversies that mark
churchill's nine decade life
and six decade parliamentary career
since its publication last month in
britain churchill walking with destiny
has been declared the best single volume
life of churchill ever written by both
the sunday times and the sunday
telegraph and in the new issue of finest
hour the international churchill
society's publication reviewer john
campbell hailed it as a heroic biography
andrew roberts is a phd from cambridge
university is a visiting professor at
the war studies department of kings
college london the lairman institute
distinguished lecturer at the new york
historical society
and the author of 13 books including
eminent churchillians the storm of war
masters and commanders and napoleon he
is a trustee of the margaret thatcher
archive trust the national portrait
gallery and of course most importantly
the international churchill society
ladies and gentlemen it is my great
pleasure to introduce andrew roberts
[Applause]
might it be possible to have a copy of
the book here displayed
thank you very much yeah exactly always
display them right also um there's
something i might draw attention to in a
bit later
so i mentioned in my introduction that
you had used um a great many new sources
and some might ask how could there
possibly be new sources after more than
a thousand biographies of churchill but
you found them could you tell us about
those yes there have been one thousand
and nine biographies of churchill
um and um so why on earth could i impose
a 1010 from the public
um
over the last decade a extraordinary
cornucopia of new sources has opened up
um imaginary the queen allowed me to be
the first churchill biographer to use
her father's diaries
and king george vi gave an interview to
an audience to winston churchill every
tuesday lunchtime of the second world
war and then wonderfully went and wrote
down everything that churchill said
and so we have huge amounts of new
information about his hopes and fears
and appears sue and some gags uh every
tuesday of the war
we also have 41 oh and the relationship
between the king and and churchill was a
fascinating one it need not have been
very successful at the beginning it
could easily have gone wrong
churchill of course uh had supported the
king's elder brother during the
abdication crisis
and the um king had also very much been
in favor of the policy of appeasement
and had tried to stop churchill for
becoming prime minister so it was a uh
it could have gone wrong that
relationship instead it went
magnificently right
and very quickly the
uh king was referring to uh churchill by
his christian name it's the first time
he'd ever it was the only one of his
prime ministers for prime ministers who
he called by his christian name and they
became firm friends he uses the word
friendship in the um in the diaries
you also have 41 sets of papers that
have been deposited at the churchill
college in archives in in cambridge
since the
big last big biography of him including
mary soames's
1940 diary you have the
diaries of ivan maeske the soviet
ambassador in 1932-43
who churchill saw a lot of especially
during the nazi soviet pact you have the
verbatim accounts of the war cabinets
now those have been discovered in the
last 10 years and also um there's
another
fascinating um
new
um
i'm trying to work out the best ways of
putting this um pamela harriman's love
letters
um
pamela harriman i'm very conscious of
the fact we're on tv uh led a
active romantic life during the second
world war
um
and uh so we have these uh these love
lessons she actually
and i was given exclusive access to them
she um
had had love affairs with people all
around churchill who knew churchill and
wrote backwards and forwards to um
to churchill so you have these letters
from people like um
jock whitney um
the
ed murrow the the great broadcaster um
of course she's married all the way
through this time to to winston
churchill's son randolph had a baby by
him um but also you get love letters
from uh bill paley and from of course um
avril harriman himself who was the
fdr's special envoy
the head of the raf so charles portal
general kenneth anderson
and someone we just know of as jerry
it's uh you put all these together and
there is something new something that
won't have appeared all of these new
sources uh on every page of uh of my
book
and you use these sources in your many
many years of experience researching
churchill to take readers along with
churchill on his walk with destiny but
this sense of destiny was present in him
from a very early age can you tell us
about that it's absolutely epicentral to
understanding him
um from the age of 16
winston churchill when he was at harrow
the church was almost totally
self-educated because he had to because
he went to harrow
he at the age of 16
told a friend that there were going to
be great struggle struggles huge
upheavals in in um in the world that he
was going to be called upon to save
london and save the country and save the
empire
and he said this at
16 and he believed it
and he acted out his life um very much
under that sense of self belief this
sense of destiny
and
as he went through life and especially
as he survived incredibly large number
of um brushes with death with close
brushes with death
i could go through them but there were
an enormous number um he believed as a
result the almighty that there were what
he called invisible wings
that were flapping over him and
protecting him and
although when you look into the role of
the almighty in churchill's theology it
seems to have
mainly
been designed just simply to take care
of winston churchill
one of the most extraordinary things
about churchill becoming prime minister
in may 1940
was that he survived
long enough to reach that office you
mentioned just a minute ago uh his
various scrapes and and uh near misses
can you tell us yes yes okay let's go
through them i'll try and keep them
roughly chronological um
he was born two months premature
he was stabbed in the stomach by a pen
knife um when he was at prep school age
10. aged 11 he had very serious
pneumonia probably the closest he ever
came to death and his doctors
administered brandy to him both orally
and rectally
you would have thought that might have
put you off brandy for life ladies and
gentlemen but in church's case it
certainly didn't um
he had um he survived a near drowning on
lake geneva a house fire um of course he
fought in um in five wars on uh on four
continents um in the first world war he
went into the trenches uh into no man's
land sorry uh 30 times which he didn't
need to do as a battalion commander of
then commanding the sikh battalion of
the royal scots fusiliers but he did got
so close to the german trenches that he
could hear the germans speaking in them
it was um
he survived two plane crashes uh three
car crashes and this here the reason
that i've brought this here um apart
from obviously to encourage you to buy
it um is to um is to show you this livid
scar
um down the center of his forehead which
came as a result of his car crash in in
fifth avenue in new york in december
1931.
and it didn't stop with the uh war
either he
when the war started he continued to
take extraordinary risks um again and
again especially during the blitz and he
also had a minor heart attack when he
was lifting a sash window at the white
house in
1941 and uh also he got a series of
of pneumonia later on in his life and in
carthage in the may of 1943 he had a
very serious bout um
his doctor asked him to um provide some
blood
and um churchill said well i can give
you some from my
finger or from my ear and i also have an
almost infinite expanse of arse
so we we when we think of churchill most
of us think about this fierce bulldog
image on the cover but one of the things
that you've discovered in your research
is that churchill was remarkably
lacrimos even when he held the highest
office
absolutely
he was a profoundly passionate and
emotional man much more than i was
expecting actually he but he uh he was
he burst into tears 50 times during the
second world war it must be very
off-putting to have your leader suddenly
just burst into tears in the house of
commons if theresa may suddenly burst
into tears i think it would be very
off-putting although she's got every
right to
um
i would um
[Music]
say i would put this down to the fact
that he was not a buttoned up um
tory stiff up upper lip aristocrat of
the late victorian age
into which he was born but much more
that he was a throwback to an earlier
era
an era he loved that of the regency
aristocracy
people who wore their heart on their
sleeve very much
very much more than the victorians did
as long as we're on the subject of
churchill's emotions i think we should
deal with as you do in your book this
this perception on the part of many that
churchill was depressive or manic
depressive yes or something along the
way yes i i don't i don't believe that's
the case at all um certainly not uh
bipolar as some of the um of the books
have said no he was he got depressed
undoubtedly he got depressed
through the time of the dardanelles
catastrophe in the first world war which
had led to the killing or wounding of
160 000 allied troops which he had
entirely supported right from the
beginning all the way through to the end
he got depressed at the time of the fall
of singapore in february 1942 in the
fall of to brook in june 1942
um but these are times really when
anyone would have got depressed
and depression is a debilitating illness
and it can attack at any time and he was
able to chair over a thousand meetings
of the cabinet's
wall of the defense committee at any
time day and night until uh until three
am in the morning sometimes
and that's not the mark of the
depressive neither was he an alcoholic
again he did he did drink an enormous
amount um cp scott said that winston
churchill couldn't be an alcoholic
because no alcoholic could have drunk
that much
um
and uh and when you um when you look at
the amount that he uh that he drunk um
you have to remember that he was a he
had an ox-like constitution
and of the uh
2174 days of the second world war
there's only one day that people around
him said that he was uh drunk
and uh and on that occasion they ignored
um everything that had been decided that
night and had precisely the same meeting
the next morning when he'd sobered up
and uh and so no decisions were taken on
the back of his of his drinking but i um
very much came to the conclusion by the
end of researching this book that he um
that in his words of course were correct
when he said that alcohol was uh
that he'd taken more out of alcohol than
alcohol had taken out of him
you very firmly established in this book
and in your comments now that churchill
was neither a depressive nor a drunk but
when you look at his parents and how
they treated him you might not blame him
for uh either of those afflictions can
you tell us about his uh his parents
especially his father's treatment of
them yes um i think some of the um his
father lord randolph churchill um was a
brilliant mercurial disdainful aloof
figure who had been chancellor of the
exchequer and one of the great orators
in english politics
and um and he never spotted any um
any part of um of brilliance in his own
son uh instead he lambasted him some of
the most moving letters are the letters
that uh in this book are the letters
from churchill begging really for love
and affection from his parents his
mother
was born in brooklyn of course and um
and yet didn't
she seem to take on the english
victorian attitude of
towards children when she was
when winston was 10 years old she wrote
everything that she did in her diary in
1884 and she only saw her son
six and a half hours out of six months
and um and he said churchill said
that he felt um
that she was and wrote in her in his
brilliant autobiography my early life um
that he felt um that she was like the
evening star in that she shone
brilliantly but at a distance and that
obviously had a deep psychological
effect on him but the effect and then
she showed no she showed no interest in
him until he became a signatory on her
trust fund
at which point suddenly he she actually
started to be extremely helpful and nice
to him um but with with regard to the
father after the father's death um
in 1894 at the age of 45 when churchill
was 20 churchill um
proved his his
love of
almost obsession with his father he
wrote his father's two-volume biography
he searched out all his father's friends
he adopted his father's political stance
um of uh benjamin disraeli's um tory
democracy he adopted his father's actual
speaking stance of putting his hand on
his head he uh called his son randolph
and then when he finally made some money
basically winston churchill was in the
red until these early 70s
when finally he had some cash to spend
because he'd written his war memoirs
he did a very regency thing which was to
spend it on the first of 37 racehorses
and he put um the jockeys of the
racehorses into his father's pink and
chocolate racing colours
churchill fought and wrote his way all
over the world and time and again he
displayed a kind of of extraordinary
even reckless courage that that many of
his contemporaries were just amazed at
he said later that courage is the first
of human qualities because it's the
quality that guarantees all the others
you of course
tell us a great deal about churchill's
courage
in your book could you discuss
that and how that was important to his
career and his ultimate success yes and
the physical courage um that was
manifest um from very early on he um he
charged of course with the 21st lancers
at the battle of onderman and whether
where his units lost 25 casualties
following year he
um his train was ambushed in the boer
war and they lost 34 casualties and a
couple of months after that he escaped
from a prisoner of war camp and um made
his way across 300 miles of enemy
territory to uh to escape
he um
was a man compounded of courage and you
saw this this was very much a
preparation for this hour in this trial
because you saw it again in the second
world war when as a
um prime minister he traveled 110 000
miles outside of the uk
in uh in those five years of being prime
minister wartime prime minister
and um he went in planes um across the
atlantic one of which got struck by
lightning and if the instrumentation had
failed he'd have been killed he went
across the atlantic of course with um
u-boats um
in the area where they had to move the
constantly be changing direction to
avoid u-boats he flew in unpressurized
cabins at the age of his late 60s and
early 70s
in areas that um that the were being
patrolled by the luftwaffe and so it was
and were several planes that he had been
in got shot down the next day or ones
that were coming to him were shot down
it was a um it was a tremendous thing he
needed to do it because he was the glue
that kept the big three together
stalin refused to fly and only left
russia once during the second world war
um
of course fdr was profoundly disabled
and although he did go to um several of
the conferences it really took churchill
to to go all the way to um to moscow
twice and so on in order to um to be the
glue that um kept the big three together
as his walk with destiny um
entered the 1930s he became
the first one of the first at least
um
high-level prominent political leaders
in britain to spot the danger of hitler
why him what about his background and
experience helped him perceive what so
many others could not
um well i think there were three things
i think firstly he was a phylocomite
unlike many of his background and class
and uh and age uh he liked jews he'd
grown up with jews he got on holiday
with the jews his father would like jews
he thought the jews gave the ethics to
world civilization and he felt
comfortable
around jews and so he had an early
warning system for hitler and the nazis
and what they were genuinely like in a
way that a lot of other british upper
class people um who were anti-semitic
just simply didn't have
the next thing was that he was a um
historian
and so he was able to place and a
historian of his own great ancestor john
churchill first duke of marlborough who
um and he wrote a four-volume biography
of
of his great ancestor um who had of
course prevented the hegemonization of
the continent by louis xiv in the war of
spanish succession
so he was able to place hitler in the
long continuum of um people who needed
to be stopped on the continent starting
with philip ii of spain at the time of
the armada going on to louis xiv then to
napoleon and then obviously to the
kaiser and so he was able to see hitler
in the historical perspective
and the last reason was that he had come
up close to fanaticism in his own life
in a way that very few other prime
ministers of the 1930s ever had he had
seen it in the northwest frontier he'd
seen it in the sudan he'd seen um in
this case islamic fundamentalist
fanaticism
and um
he spotted it again he spotted the same
traits in the nazis and uh and hitler um
and this was something that was simply
not vouchsafe to people like um
neville chamberlain or stanley baldwin
or ramsey macdonald and none of whom had
seen anything like
that kind of fanaticism in their lives
once his walk with destiny concluded and
he became prime minister in may 1940 one
of his most potent weapons was of course
his rhetoric and his famous speeches
especially in the early part of his
premiership
which many of us know some of us know by
by heart
tell us about where this rhetorical
power came from and the influences that
went into it including perhaps william
shakespeare
yes yes i do recommend the um uh
shakespeare exhibition the churchill
shakespeare exhibition because it knows
yes it
um at the moment which concentrates on
the extent to which william shakespeare
and churchill's love of shakespeare from
very early age and his and his learning
of great great reams of shakespeare
affected um churchill's oratorical
technique but actually even at the age
of 23 churchill had written an article
called the scaffolding of rhetoric which
explains the five things you need to do
in order to be able to capture an
audience in a public speech and at that
point it was entirely theory because at
that point he had never given a public
speech himself
and so it was he took it from the theory
into the practice he then um traveled
tens of thousands of miles up and down
the country
to give speeches all over the all over
the country as a as a young budding
politician and um he was
able therefore to to put his theories
into practice in a completely brilliant
way he had a um
uh
he had a problem in that he wasn't a
natural speaker he had a sibilant s
he um had to work incredibly hard at it
but he knew how important it was and so
he did put in the hours necessary and he
was um in 1940 one of his private
secretaries asked him what the what the
secret to his uh great wartime speeches
were and he said that you needed to keep
words short you needed to work out for
yourself what you wanted to say and keep
total clarity of the message and you
needed to keep sentences short and if
possible use words from old english
um which would um which would narrowly
uh
naturally sort of appeal to um to the um
people listening to it in in the english
language and
when you look at the 141 word perration
of his we shall fight on the beaches
speech which of course talks about we
shall fight with growing confidence in
the air and ends
we shall never surrender of those 141
words all but two of them
come from the
old english
of those two
confidence the word confidence comes
from the latin and surrender comes from
the french
[Laughter]
indeed um
churchill's
rhetoric was of course a formidable
weapon but he was also
a a war leader who commanded of what
became ultimately a vast
war
effort one of the things that that
marked it out from the beginning was its
determination to coordinate it can you
talk about the lessons that he derived
from his earlier experiences in the
first world war and in other conflicts
that he brought
to 10 downing street as prime minister
in may 1940. yes what i mentioned about
the horror of the gallipoli campaign the
dardanelles where 160 000 uh allies
casualties were suffered and he um
ensured that he was never again going to
be in a position
where um that was going to happen
because he was never in the second world
war to overrule the chiefs of staff in
the way that he had overruled the
admiralty in the in the great war and so
he never once did in the whole of the uh
in the whole of the um of the war so he
wasn't he was a politician who learned
lessons
learned from his mistakes
and um
[Music]
and also of course he knew that he had
made endless errors all the way through
his life he had got so many things wrong
he got women's suffrage wrong he got the
gold standard wrong he got the
abdication crisis wrong he got the
primarily of course gallipoli wrong and
many others
and uh so he was a genius but he was a
flawed genius and he knew that and he
also knew that he had to learn from his
mistakes
in fact he told his wife clementine i
should have made nothing if i had not
made mistakes
tell us um since you mentioned
clementine tell us about clementine
churchill and how important she was to
him they were married for a very very
long time
she was central absolutely central to
his um existence she gave him the some
of the best advice that he had for his
career she told him not to come out of
the trenches too early in the second in
the first world war which was a very
difficult piece of advice to tell um him
because of course he was taking these
risks and going off into into the trench
raiding um and and she knew that and yet
she she also knew that he would never be
happy in life uh if he support the
reputation that he had by returning too
early in june 1940 she writes in the
marvellous letter telling him not to be
so beasty to the staff
and be nicer to the private secretaries
and the stenographers and the
secretaries and the rest of it um
because he was he was just being too
egotistical and bullying and uh and rude
and difficult and and that seems to have
worked at least for a moment
um
he was um
he was he always thought of her as his
uh rock and um and depended on her
enormously and the wonderful thing about
her is that she could be she was an
aristocratic battle axe basically and
she could be so rude to his political
enemies uh and um and you you certainly
didn't want to get on the wrong side of
um of clementine churchill when she was
in full um swing and um this marvellous
letter that she writes to
to um henry asquith the
herbert asquith the prime minister in
1915 in which she
tells him that he needs to
re-employ
churchill and not let him leave the the
admiralty
and although it got him
nowhere and got her nowhere and the ass
was rather sniffy about the letter
actually when you read it today you
would be so proud as a man to have a
wife who could write a letter like that
absolutely magnificent
actually i've got a wife who could write
a letter like that in fact
i i strongly suspect that we have a very
large number of questions uh
from the audience and so i think we will
turn to that now uh if you do have a
question please raise your hand
anyone we've got one
over there we've got a microphone that
will come together
lady in red back there
here we are
hello thank you very much and it was a
voice of america
eurasian service i have very a very
specific question so you know uh the
question of the caucasus and the british
withdrawal was in a way debated between
lord carson and churchill so could you
expand on that what role did
you know churchill has
have in this
uh
and i mean like after the first world
war the withdrawal of the uk from the
region thank you yes it was the it was
the question really in um september and
october
1922 that brought down the the um
lloyd george government and it was a
uh really
went to the heart of what the british
empire was going to be about um because
the government lloyd george and
churchill and others wanted to
to ensure that turkey stuck to the um
provisions of the serve treaty and um
which were very harsh on turkey
and the um
[Music]
uh the turks weren't going to
to do it and it was um
if people had supported the government
we would have possibly gone to war with
turkey which nobody wanted to do four
years after the end of the great war and
so um others such as
andrew bona law
really brought down the government in
order to prevent
this from happening so were we going to
be a continuingly pugnacious imperial
power the policeman of the world as um
as bona lord put it in the um in a
letter to the times um or were we gonna
stand back and and effectively accept
that we were going to be a declining
power and the um and the what was called
the carlton club meeting on the 19th of
october 1922 made it clear that it was
going to be the latter
gentleman in the bow tie chair chilean
bowtie
hi
thank you for coming sir thank you
michael for doing this and everyone at
the churchill center um in christopher
andrews book defend
to defend the realm is a history of mi5
one of the things that struck me was is
that
churchill
the impression i had was is that
churchill was almost fighting a
two-front war
in the run-up
to him becoming prime minister that he
was also he was concerned with the rise
of fascism
but he was also concerned about the rise
of communism at the same time and no one
wanted it was almost some in some
circles in some policy circles it seems
like it was an either or
and i just wondered if you if your book
speaks to
him trying to
trying to address that and get people to
take it seriously
oh absolutely you know chapter after
chapter does um it's from the bolshevik
revolution onwards he was a convinced
anti-communist um but by the
late 1930s certainly by 1939 he believed
that it was essential to get the soviet
union into a defensive pact in order to
stop hitler
which of course had many problems not
least because the polls um were
essential to this but but they quite
rightly um feared and um and
despised the russians as much as the
germans so
it was a really complicated geostrategic
decision
that churchill took to embrace the
soviet union which he had been
denouncing uh for uh for the previous um
you know decade and a bit um
he did it partly um
with the help of ivan maeske the uh the
ambassador so we now do have new
information about the extent to which he
was um he was doing this and there is a
chance um that
you mentioned the christopher andrew
book which is the the um substantial
biography of mi5 there's a chance that
he was being bugged by mi5 um because
they obviously needed to know what was
being said between him and uh and my ski
it's a it's a it's a pretty gray area of
course like everything else in the
intelligence world
but um nothing came of it of course
ultimately because the nazi soviet pact
um in april in august 1939 managed to
leapfrog anything that the the national
government were able to do
question
yes ma'am
with this much material to choose from
i'm curious
how you decided what not to include and
is there anything you didn't include in
your book that you could share with us
tonight
the lady standing at the back there um
in the blue is joy de mannille who was
my uh editor um
and uh she knows better than anybody in
the world what not what what we did and
what we didn't uh include basically it
could have been 10 times bigger couldn't
it joy yeah
she said it was stretched to the limits
of the binding um and and you have to do
that because there's just so much to say
about churchill um but the real problem
i found in writing this book um
was to was what to what to cut out um it
was con condensation condensation
conditioner the whole time one had to
condense um and sometimes it's like
chopping off your little finger you know
you you've gone off to an archive you'll
have found a beautiful nugget that
you're very proud of um and then you
just have don't have to have space for
it and it's it's a it's a horrible
feeling but you've just got to do it
because otherwise um you're either
forced into two volumes which doesn't
sell anything like so well um
or you um
have something that if you drop it on
your toe it would break your leg
um
but but i think with this one um i hope
you'll agree with this one although it
is um it's got a hunt right at the end
are about 150 pages of notes
bibliography and index that you don't
have to have to worry about the actual
bit that's that's the the meaty part is
under a thousand pages
actually it's 18 pages under a thousand
pages
james
could you talk about the
modern case against churchill and how
you consider it but a feather on the
scale of history
yes yes no this is very important
especially since the um
especially since the
um internet the um
the attacks on churchill have become
ever more
um
some of them
frankly weird but um but but i saw the
other day about your um astronaut scott
kelly um the the un ambassador to space
only the united nations would send an
ambassador to a place that hasn't got a
country a government or a people but
nonetheless um
this man
said that um
that
[Music]
he quoted churchill saying
um in victory magnanimity
and um in in a tweet and he got an
enormous number of um of twitter um
trolls saying that churchill was a
racist and a colonialist and a war
criminal and all of this kind of thing
and um all the old canards came up the
gassing of the iraqi tribesmen
etc etc which
let me just point out ladies and
gentlemen it's very clear when you go to
the original documents uh he was talking
about tear gas he was not talking about
mustard gas he actually made that clear
in the in the letter again and again
with these things you just need to go
back to the um
to the to the original sources or what
mr kelly should have done is just
educate himself about churchill instead
he put out a uh tweet saying that he
that he was very sorry that um that he
should have said anything in favor of
this evil uh racist uh you know
warmonger
and um and then he got all the pro
churchill people um
uh tweeting him i really do think though
the the the space that mr kelly should
have concentrated on really is the one
between his ears
how about that gentleman is that
in america for about 30 years after the
war there was this portrait of the grand
alliance and everybody had gotten along
and then more and more books started to
point out the shameful way that franklin
roosevelt treated winston churchill it
is my personal opinion maybe someone
will troll me but the
question i guess is do you have any
sense of how he personally felt about
the way he was treated at york
yes i i think it's too harsh
very very much too harsh to say that it
was shameful i think uh fdr put american
best interests first which is the duty
of an american president so i don't
think that um because they they didn't
go to war against russia which you'd
have had to have done in order to impose
the
agreement that made at yalta um
that
fdr can be accused of that he did pivot
from the tehran conference onwards um
towards trying to make sure that there
was a long-term
arrangement with the
with the russians which of course came
to grief at yalta but what happened at
yalta reddy was that stalin lied all the
way through about the integrity and
independence of poland and you still had
over a million russian boots on polish
soil and without
going to war with russia it seems very
difficult to work out how on earth
anything could have been done about that
and so
it was a it was a um
a terrible moment when um by march 1946
and the
uh the iron curtain speech at fulton
missouri churchill was the first person
just as brave as anything he said in the
1930s and he got just as much publicly
for it as a result came out and said
that soviet communism understanding was
going to be
a a scourge and um and so
of course by that stage um
um
fdr was dead
but um
that you're right in saying where i
think you're right is saying that from
the autumn of 1944 onwards the close
friendly relaxed working relationship
between the two men had broken down and
there are over 300 more letters i think
it's 342
more letters from winston churchill to
franklin roosevelt then there are
replies from roosevelt to um to
churchill so maybe that's what you're
referring to when you um when you use
the word shameful
yes ma'am in the blue i just wait for
one second we'll bring the microphone to
you
could you explain um
churchill's relationship with our
presidents post-world war ii i i was
under the impression that they shared
our national intelligence information
with him when he was in because he
returned back as prime minister so i'm
i'm pretty sure
truman and um eisenhower both and
probably kennedy both sent him our
national security information no kennedy
not kennedy but um truman and eisenhower
and and i wanted to point out that in
your imperial war museum you only have
one book on
on general montgomery and it's comparing
him with rommel
[Laughter]
and could you expand upon his
relationship with general montgomery
well first of all and the imperial war
museum has undertaken the most
terrible disbursement of books they've
sold they've sold their library
basically um and um it's uh it's one of
the great historical tragedies um and
that's why they'll only have one book
there if you asked that question five
years ago um there would have been well
over 300 books in the imperial war
museum on on montgomery um his
relationship with montgomery was um was
subject to fluctuations um
he admired him very much at the
beginning made him a um
field marshal very early on um in 1944
to the fury of patton and
omar bradley and various other
people who wanted to be five star
generals at the time who weren't um he
then um thought that monty
got too big for his boots um which monty
most definitely had um
uh he then um befriended monty in the
uh interwar in sorry in the post-war
period and then um and to a great degree
where monty i think monty went round to
chart will stayed at charlotte will or
had lunch at charles 78 times um in the
um in the course of the uh of the
post-war um premiership and then
he fell out with monty again so they it
was they were like two
as he said of his relationship with
general smuts they were like two old
birds pegging each other um but they but
they ultimately of course there was a
great deal of um of respect and
admiration was there a first part of the
question i've forgotten sorry
oh i see yes no um
well of course he he like everybody else
churchill liked ike um but he actually
wanted adele stevenson to win um the um
the 1952 election
and um
he was uh
he was nerve-racked because he thought
that eisenhower wasn't going to pursue
the
um policy of
basically policy of nuclear appeasement
that he wanted to pursue towards the
russians after the russians exploded
their nuclear bomb in april 1949. at
that point the great antique
anti-communist anti-soviet
winston churchill who of course had been
pro-soviet during the war and then
anti-soviet in 1946 at the time of the
iron curtain speech then went pro um
again because he saw that british
interests were not uh best served by
having a um a heavily nuclearized soviet
union he thought that eisenhower would
not address that whereas the democrats
might
yes sir
we have a microphone
right here
thank you also for coming here it's been
a real treat and having read your book
on halifax
many many years ago
and
uh i can't wait to read your book on
churchill you probably get this question
a lot
since the darkest hour came out in the
movie
uh and now being an expert obviously on
both of the leading characters in that
what is your
take on the movie um do you think that
the artistic license that they took was
necessary to get the story out to a
wider audience i'm just curious as your
thoughts
thank you very much for um reading my
first book the holy fox the biography of
lord halifax i rate it 30 years ago
since when i've written five other books
with churchill in the title or the
subtitle i really feel as though um i
i was walking with destiny and that all
my past life has been a preparation for
this hour uh and this uh and this trial
um
the um
the the i love the film i thought it was
great i loved um i loved gary oldman's
prosthetics i loved the sort of glint in
the eye and the chortle uh he i thought
he caught churchill absolutely
brilliantly um
the
problem i had with it was that it
actually detracted from the true
leadership that was shown uh by winston
churchill in may 1940 over the issue of
making peace with adolf hitler where he
did not go down into the subway and
treat um
and ask a focus group of people in his
uh
what he wanted to do uh what he should
do neither was he visited by the king in
his bedroom at midnight at number 10
downing street that didn't happen either
um and so as a result you actually have
a detraction from the extraordinary uh
leadership that he did show he um he
decided that he was going to outmaneuver
lord halifax he didn't go to mps he went
to the wider cabinet um he put forward
well it's all in chapter 21 of my of my
book it's uh it was a it was a
campaign to ensure especially of course
once we'd got 250 000 troops back from
dunkirk by the 28th of may um that these
um peace negotiations were never going
to go anywhere and it's absolutely it's
one of those pivotal moments in history
that if they had if hannifex had been
prime minister and if neville james
continued his prime minister and had
supported halifax we could have gone
down a very very dangerous path
uh if we'd made peace with hitler then
because he would have then been able to
have instead of using 50 to 70 percent
of the luftwaffe on operation barbarossa
the attack on russia on the 22nd of june
1941 he'd been able to have used it all
and when you think that he got to in the
north he got to
subject leningrad to a grueling thousand
day siege and in the center he uh got to
the subway stations of moscow and in the
south he actually captured stalingrad
what he'd have been able to have done if
he'd had the whole luftwaffe twice as
many planes is um terrifying to uh to
consider especially without america
being in the war at the time
right back there
see a hand there
this young fellow yes
i was wondering if you could talk about
um churchill's role in the attack on the
french at mirzel kabir very good
question
um
yes it was something that almost broke
his heart he was a francophile to the
end he loved um he loved france always
had done um but when it became clear
that the actually nothing was terribly
clear about the we called it oran as
well merzed and or
nothing was terribly clear because um
although we were intercepting the french
naval um
naval um signals uh they weren't always
being done in real time and also not um
completely successfully
so
churchill um believed that the french
fleet was not going to scuttle itself
this is of course the vichy fleet that
was in the in the algerian port of
meselcobia or iran
um but was actually going to try and
fight it out and take on uh admiral uh
sir james somerville's force
and so churchill had to take this this
grindingly painful uh decision
especially of course as the uh this was
on the third of july 1940 only two weeks
before um
the uh the germans had marched into
paris
of not just um setting back any hope for
close anglo-french cooperation
um but also killing
three thousand as it turned out
is it three thousand so i know it wasn't
i think
sorry twelve yes nearly thirteen hundred
twenty twelve hundred and ninety nine
um french soldiers
and so um
he took that decision it was one that he
um
he never regretted
and
one of the reasons was that it sent the
message to the world and especially here
to the united states that we were going
to fight on come what may if you sink
the french fleet and they were your
allies only two weeks beforehand it's
clear that you're not about to give up
and uh and uh
make peace with uh hitler
very good question can you discuss the
the reaction of the
comments well the house of commons of
course cheered um cheer churchill to the
echo and he cried as he so often did as
i mentioned earlier
um
and um
but but he hated doing it and uh and
said so um but nonetheless uh it was it
was the first victory we'd had for some
time and uh and of course actually the
other thing is uh the royal navy itself
split between the officers who had um
been uh who knew other french
officers and uh they've been on each
other's ships and trained with each
other and and knew each other and liked
each other who were devastated by having
to um to kill so many frenchmen
and then the abel seaman um who um just
thought that they were something
straight out of trafalgar and uh and and
nelson and absolutely um didn't mind in
the slightest
we have a couple more questions this
young man right here on the front please
um again um i just want to say thank you
for being here
my question is what are your thoughts as
to why he
was not re-elected in right after the
war do you think
maybe because when the war ended people
saw him as a symbol of the old order he
was an imperialist and they wanted to
basically start anew
yes that's um that's one aspect of it um
he it came as a terrible shock when he
lost the 1945 general election on the
26th of july he was um
uh he expected to win because he'd been
on one after the other after the other
of these election tours where he'd been
cheered to the echo especially in the
northern and the midlands towns
um but of course his name was was only
on one ballot um whereas uh whereas the
a lot of conservatives who had been
appeasers um
their names were on the others and
people wanted after six years of
devastating war wanted to have
a um
a more
um
well they they wanted nationalization
they wanted the national health service
they wanted the um
uh the welfare state and the and the
beverage report put into um operation
and they knew that it was going to be uh
labor clement and his labour party that
would do that um
with um with gusto whereas although
churchill did offer to do most of that
um he would um
not do it with anything like the same
conviction and that's essentially what i
mean he also made an incredibly stupid
remark during the election
where he attempted to equate uh atlas
labour party with the gestapo
which was an extremely stupid thing to
have done and probably also lost us a
few seats
i think we have time for one more
question sir here
of all the churchill biographers out
of all the churchill biographers out
there how were you able to convince the
queen to give you unfettered access
to her father's diaries um it was it was
i'd love to pretend it was um
uh anything other than serendipity i
just
i didn't take no for an answer and i
kept asking which i think is always very
sensible with the royal archives um also
you know it has been 70 plus years um
since the events and
so i think that it was pretty much time
that
of course that's a decision to be taken
between her and christopher geiter
her private secretary so uh luckily they
came to the decision that i was going to
get a yes rather than yet another now
but um but as i say i'd love to pretend
it was archival genius it wasn't at all
ladies and gentlemen i'd like to invite
all of you to join us here on monday
november 26th when we welcome sir
anthony beaver who will discuss his new
history of the battle of arnhem that's
november 26th at noon
and now i hope that you will take your
own personal walk with destiny over to
the book
[Laughter]
ladies and ensure the education and the
future of andrew's children by buying
books remembering that the holidays are
just around the corner and please allow
andrew to make a dash to the signing
table over there where he will be only
too happy to give you his autograph
thank you for being here tonight and
andrew roberts thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
michelle obama is on tour for her
best-selling autobiography becoming
here's a portion of her speaking in
washington d.c
so education was